let me start with uh congratulations
love the movie love this franchise for
both of you it is um what does it
actually mean to both of you to be part
of a franchise like this that is so
beloved to so many people around the
world yeah very challenging you know has
to be satisfied for their expectation
and also they need their refreshment or
surprise so what can I do as a new face
so that's the biggest thing but uh so
happy to be a part of uh the series
sense of responsibility uh knowing that
this is such a beloved friend as you
said and knowing that as the new blood
the new guy probably the youngest guy on
set I had to bring my a game so it was a
lost Army the magnitude of working with
such Legends like hero Keanu Lance
Lawrence I mean the list goes on that I
had to come in there and really show my
stuff but to that end everybody was as
you know very humble and made the
process very enjoyable for me each of
you have you get to work with a dog
which is very a big part of the John
Wick franchise yes you get to fight
Donnie which is I mean it's I I don't
want to curse but it's effing incredible
um so can you sort of both talk a little
bit about the dog is a huge part of the
franchise yes and you get it this time
and getting to fight Donnie yeah the dog
is a through line that's the reason why
this thing even exists quite frankly
um and the experience is one thing
working with Belgian Malinois and how
incredibly skilled they are and learning
that process and then the other side of
it the responsibility of having a dog in
this film and what that holds or what
that means to everybody is when I got
the call it's like I was going to be
working with a dog let alone being in
the job like four franchise I was like
it's incredible you know do I get a spin
off you know something you know but uh
it's really great but you know in the
Donnie end of it all the hero speak on
that but I got to watch those guys fight
which is legendary
yeah it was fun uh it was first time to
work with him but uh cooperation was so
easy and then uh we put the ideas
together and um it was so much fun
because
carrying each character and emotion and
why we have to do this so each movement
has a reason and then we created the
same you know better and better and chat
just for watching us and enjoying so it
was so much fun and then I I love the
the scene for me too my last thing for
you guys this franchise has such iconic
action set pieces and I'm just curious
besides the ones that you were in which
obviously you're favoring uh which
sequence in all four movies do you love
is there one that you just can't believe
you know what I mean something
exceptional that's because I have a dog
in this version but the John worked
through with Halle Berry that dog
sequence next level like that was the
next level dog sequence so that was my
favorite one channel three
yeah I like the the scene uh the gun
fight between Kane and John Wick at the
at the end and that's a beautiful ending
scene of the series I think I'm just
gonna say congrats uh I know it's going
to be a huge hit thank you for your time